then you shave their faces you know go
full beard or nothing because the
stubble hurts my thighs
we are shaving our faces and I'm really
excited about it why are you excited one
I heard that it helps you apply makeup I
think I'm gonna do terrible many women
shave their faces okay there's no shame
some of us have mustaches guys don't
even look I've shaved my eyebrows before
when I couldn't get to the salon your
eyebrow wow that is pretty impressed
that guys can do it and not cut the crap
out of their face every day if I don't
cut myself then I'll be really proud
because there's contours that are
happening here and I can barely do my
ankles let's go do it we get up let's go
all right I'm finished shaved my face
ohh oh my god I don't want to use the
ones made for women ever again
Carl are you scared when you do this do
guys do this quickly just get over here
all right well first of all how much do
you use generally all right more than
that oh I want to stress that we are
shaving our faces for the first time but
plenty of women shave their faces smells
like a boy I like wanna make out with
myself I love this scent so much this
looks awesome just like an adorable
Santa break it up or down up or down
okay ah there is hair coming off you're
going so far oh isn't there pride in the
time of it what do I do I do this face
right oh I feel like I'm not the girl
back Oh crazy full beard
oh we're going into mustache territory I
like this part the neck is though I'm
not shaving my neck
that hurt that's very dangerous who
actually says climb erotic oh my god
you're so close to your veins do you
enjoy doing this cuz this feels really
good what I do I enjoy do this oh my god
no like I hate it
that was scary that would like being
discreet Tori oh I could go toe to toe
with a baby right now
look at that lack of mustache your skin
look really shiny you look overall I
stay a little under
my face feels amazing it feels like so
smooth I fear that looks more ready
I can't believe men just shave up here
and I felt like that was a little bit
too close to my eye I feel like the same
girl but a different man every time we
do stuff like this it makes me respect
men a little bit more I'm not gonna lie
Gabby's gonna hate me but it does for
sure do this again but your Allstate was
training Carl right see this there's a
good way to like wake up I should bring
our razor to work and like do it after
lunch or something I'm gonna use this
from now on to shave my mustache my face
feels good I like was really into myself
for a moment thought I was making out
myself on my neck like if you don't have
a man to do that you can just be sensual
like with yourself it's a little scary
I'm also proud that I didn't cut myself
so hey what's up Stan I'm an adult I
thought it was fantastic it's gonna go
kiss some people tonight whenever be
like oh my god in movies oh there are
scenes of like powerful men like shaving
yeah just money you don't see powerful
women in movies like making plans while
they like but maybe we should even be
sharing yes